نزاع السودان يدخل اسبوعه الثامن وافق
التهدئه مسدوده حتى اللحظه عدد ضحايا
ارتفع والحاجه ماسه الى المساعدات
الانسانيه اذا ما ذهبنا معكم الى
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وحتى قوات
الدعم السريع استمرت في عده مناطق
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وخصوصا مع
تركيزها شمالي مدينه الخرطوم بحري عند هذه
النقطه كما نتابع طبعا تلك هذه الشبكات
تزامنت مع قصف جوي هذا القصف الجوي نفذه
سلاح الجو السوداني مصحوبا ايضا بقصف
مدفعي خصوصا على قاعده كرري الموجوده في
هذه المنطقه حيث اعلن القوات الدعم السريع
السودانيه اسقاط طائره حربيه هذه الطائره
من طراز ميج في منطقه بحري بالتحديد عند
هذه النقطه طبعا مع احتدام الاشتباك اكثر
فاكثر في هذه المناطق وعوده الطائرات
المقاتله في سماء الخرطوم كانت دعت
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه دع
الطرفين لاتفاق على وقف جديد لاطلاق نار
وتنفيذي بشكل فعال بهدف وقف دائم للعمليات
العسكريه في وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في
الرياض وان اعلنت ان واشنطن والرياض
حريصتان على استمرار المحادثات مع وفدي
الجيش والدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات